hey we never fit - I wouldn't experience
that again like Sora's just blasting off
well hey everybody welcome to another
episode of hot boxing with Mike Tyson I
am Evan Britton and I'm Mike Tyson there
he is my brother how are you today mount
a mean this is awesome we have such an
interesting guest today oh man dude
strap on your seat belts brother head
now well we've got dr. gerardo sand of
all isaac or dr. jerry for short yep dr.
jerry man it is so awesome to have you
in here today
now it's such an honor to be here really
it's privilege it's like a dream come
true to be here
besides mike and awesome see how mike
brings people together she's pretty
amazing and he offers this platform to
educate and have awesome conversations
like we're gonna have today no thank you
Mike just as a start we're here at the
ranch we are very all about the positive
message of cannabis as a medicine you
know our country is slowly coming to
realize the medicinal benefits of
cannabis about time right and and you I
know that you are among other things a
cannabis advocate absolute ace level yes
but promoting the use of cannabis and
especially the medicinal properties of
cannabis in Mexico huge fan of the RSO
or yeah Rick sent oil in some oil
absolutely yes awesome the medicine
that's awesome man but even more
fascinating is bufo alvarius now tell us
tell us a little bit exotic what is bufo
alvarius well bufo alvarius is the
scientific name of the Sonoran Desert
toad
this amazing being produces in its venom
one of the I think the most or the
strongest antigen substance in the world
told a toad the venom of the toad and we
vaporize it in a pipe or in advice and
it really induces the strongest
experience it's like free BASE jumping
into the heart of God where I'm coming
back in just 20 minutes right that's all
that we can I find this stuff that's an
amazing description man so what we're
talking about is five Meo DMT that is
the active compound yeah the main
compounding the venom of the total now
for people who don't know tell us what
an entheogenic substance is well antigen
refers basically to any substance
capable of generating God within the
self well that's that's pretty profound
yes
simple a simple definition and we're not
dealing in any religious you know a
perfect it's just like a spiritual
experience by itself I've had my
experiences with ayahuasca which DMT is
one of the main ingredients along with a
Mao Mao inhibitor
yep which they have to brew and say for
a long time that is correct into this
tea and that has a very profound
entheogenic effect but something amazing
about the bufo alvarius is that it just
comes right out of this toad ready to go
pretty much that is correct there is no
need for human intervention there's no
decoction there's it's a Mother Nature's
brew and it not only contains 5 ml DMT
which is now called the God molecule but
also 20 different compounds which at
least half of them are unknown
tryptamines so and I mean this is
mothers nature's best brew I believe
this is the most updated and intelligent
medicine available for us nowadays I
want to get into
what it does specifically as far as what
it has been shown to help people with
what it's been shown to treat and cure
even but first how did you come to this
how did you discover this incredible
molecule well I was always fascinated by
the pre-hispanic sacred medicines of
Mexico and I heard about this toad that
lives in the desert and that with just
one puff it would take you right to it
so I had it like in a bucket list that
was like my hope one day I get to meet
this toad and thanks to a very powerful
experience with the peyote cactus in
Mexico I had an epiphany and I realized
that I was born to become a doctor so I
bounced back to medicine school and I
had the honor of going to wah haka which
is the place where it's famous for its
sacred mushrooms so there's little Gerry
16 years old having a huge amount of
these mushrooms from Oaxaca and I
literally went to source and came back I
defeated that I had a very profound
experience and I was like I'm I have to
meet more about these substances No and
so when I finished med school I went
back to this town of the sacred
mushrooms and I became the local doctor
off of that town and living there as a
doctor two guys from the Bay Area said
hey doc like are you fond of DMT and I'm
like yeah I'm aware of DMT would you
like to have a puff like we've got some
really good DMT yeah sure why not
dude it was a toad like as soon as I
came back from that puff I was like this
is not DMT this is I think this is a
toad I could like taste the totem I
couldn't explain I just knew with every
single cell that that was a toad and
they were like yep doc that's the toad
and I'm like um I'm hooked but not
hooked in that way I'm just in complete
awe that one puff had the power of a
gigantic dose of mushrooms and without
dealing with any physical symptoms or
digestion or puking no no no no it was
just one puff and boom I was there and I
had the strongest experience of my life
I was like
I'm gonna dedicate my life in sharing
this powerful medicine and now it's been
almost 14 years more than 5000 people
served and and still counting
wow man so as dr. in in this little town
are you prescribing or are you
suggesting to people or taking people on
these ceremonies well that was a local
doctor I was like the medical officer in
town and the whole town is aware of the
healing properties of the mushrooms so
Wow there's there was basically no need
for me to prescribe them people come to
this town every year on the rainy season
to have the experience with the
mushrooms interesting so it was just
like my starting point there and from
there I just yeah I started giving
lectures and without knowing I was
traveling all over the world
no that's amazing it's been an honor
what do you think Mike I mean is is five
amia is the toad something you're into
yeah I think man I think that it would
be awesome I think so too I also have
tried this this thing called combo the
frog medicine tree frog the tree frog
the green monkey frog from the Amazon
and what I thought was interesting
comparing that to what you said about
the toad and five Meo DMT is that
ingested any other way it will poison
you yes what would what would be the
effective because I think it's funny
this idea of licking the toad yeah
that's definitely the wrong idea and
meat no you can't don't don't do that
yeah sure do not lick the toad I think
that was a government imposed idea that
got out just to hurt people you know
there yeah but at the end you do not
lick this animals this medicine has to
be vaporized or smoked it has to help
you need to have a torch lighter and a
vaping device to fully inhale this
medicine any other way it's it's its
venom it's the defense mechanism of the
toad against any predator but the only
difference is that this toad from the
rest of the toads from all the world
instead of having like
lethal poisons and stuff yeah it has 5
mu DMT so the predator gets has an
experience what do you have questions
about Mike as you're prepping yourself
it's the only one particular type of
frog that told it does this yes only one
you can't do any other toad
no and this this toad is only found in a
very small area of the planet no it's in
the borderland between Mexico and
America right there do you have to kill
us toad no we don't hurt the animals
I've been milking milking the toads for
for almost 14 years and it's the same
totes that I mean well so they live
awhile they leave around 15 years
lifespan normally yeah now you have an
organization that is crowned ation yep I
am the president and founder of the bufo
alvarius foundation in Mexico and we're
now in the process of acquiring land to
designate them as natural sanctuaries so
that the toads are protected in their
natural habitat sadly nowadays now that
the people know that the toad has this
amazing medicine they're just rushing
themselves to the Sonoran Desert and
taking these toads out of their natural
habitat and taking them home when home
it is not the most suitable place for
them you know any animal taken from its
natural habitat and living in captivity
Europe shortening its lifespan they're
gonna die out of stress you're not going
to provide the same diet and you know
you're affecting and now people from the
Sonoran Desert are being affected by
these decreasing numbers no the toad
asked us a pest controller in the desert
so there's no toads
they're small pests and farmers and
people are complaining no so it's sad
yeah the the grand effect of taking
these animals out of their natural
habitat same thing with ayahuasca now
you go to Peru and there's areas where
there's just acres and acres of jungle
and there's no idea where people have to
go away deeper not behind the medicine
I'm sure
oh well that's why it's so important for
guys like you to continue spreading this
message and have your foundation where
we can protect these medicines do you
have any suggestions for people who are
being called to this this medicine is
there any anything people should
understand in particularly still if told
yeah I don't take the totes for sure but
I would definitely recommend you guys to
pick the right facilitator who to take
this medicine with because there's a
whole bunch of people now who are doing
the wrong the wrong way no way and it's
sad because you know this is such a
profound experience this is a sacred
experience at the end and I've seen you
know people who are like vampires who
are causing trauma with the medicine
rather than our healing so I've been
treating a whole bunch of people who
have PTSD because they took the toad
with the wrong person so if you're gonna
take the toad make sure it's someone
with experience
I suggest someone with at least 10 years
of experience know someone in the
medical field yeah you know it does it
doesn't have to be well you know there
are certain risks Mike like people can't
vomit and they can suffocate people have
died because they have drowned because
they were not looking for them properly
some people secrete a lot of people who
are healing secrete a lot of saliva and
stuff and it has to be you know there
has been medical emergencies that that a
medical personnel would have saved them
for sure no so it could have been
avoided yeah definitely so it doesn't
have to be me but any other person you
know like a nurse a paramedic and people
you know people who can take over you
for those 20 minutes and those are the
ideal candidates to have the experience
with so you shouldn't do it by yourself
no definitely not okay proper setting
setting at least no certain setting are
giving you 80% of the of the whole
experience if you're in the right set in
the right setting it's almost almost
guaranteed 90 80 percent that you're
gonna have a positive experience amazing
yeah is there anything anyone who
shouldn't do it
people with schizophrenic disorders
people with deep mental issues they are
not ideal candidates because they might
end up in the worst place but with the
proper medical assistance I mean
everyone is candidate air every human
deserves I think it's our birthright to
have this experience in also evoke this
experience once in a lifetime people who
are taking antidepressants should also
be with caution but yeah any other than
that there's no no medical
contraindication I mean I've treated
people with cancer with even lung
disease asthma you call it and the
Russian the of course there that's the
indication yeah yeah now something about
people with schizophrenia some I've
heard theories that schizophrenia is a
overactive pineal gland yes there's
creating way more serotonin serotonin in
a whole bunch of neurotransmitters so
that so taking in something like five
Meo DMT I mean those people it could
potentially be I had it helped reset it
yes I think at the end of the day five
Meo DMT is gonna end up having a whole
bunch of medical applications on the
medical field especially on the mind on
the brain so I wouldn't be surprised so
I was just saying like for those care
here they should take the medicine with
you know medical supervision sure we're
in the best possible scenario yeah gonna
have to try the some of this fiber
aftershow Bhutto we are gonna sometime
okay all right just check that toad out
your energy is awesome
this guy got some racket gone it was
beautiful man it was such a nose well
we're back man Wow well quite all right
Mike definitely something you have to
try again but and now I can handle that
cat I believe I can't go now know where
I'm going before I didn't know I was
like [ __ ] I'm dying
Wow
so what was it like Mike it was scary I
was scared at first paranoid one stop
stop the [ __ ] right now stop right now
explain it man
right now then I'm threatening of you'll
stop this [ __ ] I'll kill you mom
but kill your [ __ ] I'm talking crazy
in there Wow yeah I'm really talking
create a really kind of scared yeah I
start talking on panic yeah that's
normal
oh yeah absolutely man yeah Edison
definitely touches that it exposes you
to definitely to fear afraid no no no
that the deepest fear that everyone
shares is the fear of dying the fear of
of like going through actual physical
death and the medicine those ego death
so ego death can feel pretty much as
real as actual physical death so that's
that's the scary part Mike but once
you're over there
boom you know people respond like that
every person responds uniquely I've seen
a pattern there's like 21 different
human responses and yeah but what what I
saw what what what you had was a normal
normal response quite powerful though
what else can you share Mike yeah what
happened when you blasted through that
man
and then actually never really blasted
through that really trying to get it all
together right now no really that's why
I'm calling dr. Jill trying to come back
from the deck Oh interesting
so you said you black you went to heaven
and they took you to heaven and he came
back could you see these guys could you
see dr. Jerry ya can see Jerry I can see
I'm his assistant
you could see him in the room with you
still when you went on this was it like
a trip or was it yeah I can see him
moving around getting out of out of out
of your you're out of the way out of
your way
no so that you have so that you could
fully expand without any interference no
but I was happy to be there to assist
but you went through a process you had a
singularity nonetheless no but you
released a whole bunch of stuff no well
I
I basically witnessed Mike releasing all
you know things that we carry no and I
think you feel pretty lightweight now
there's actually a glow in your face
Mike yeah there really is you look like
you're glowing
well your energy is unbelievable man
it's off the charts right now bro you
got a smile on your face this is me
being my attic you know me response I'll
do that no man but I think the callosum
that's the attitude you know yes
at the same time no I tell you something
I never smoked crack before but remind
me a cracker I had two little pipes yeah
Wow and you took the whole heat brother
you did - you did great I'm really proud
of you Mike
really I bet you are well that's pretty
awesome a really a dr. Jerry for you to
kill explain if I have to do it again
it's tough
sure I'll be prepared the next time yeah
now dr. Jerry as far as that goes I mean
one can somebody do round two right
after and right after right after right
after actually when I tried it the first
time as soon as I came back
the guy said would you like to go again
I'm like no way and I hit and yes oh yes
and maybe eight years ago I had also the
chance to be with a an artist a painter
and sculptor we stayed at his studio the
whole night from 8:00 p.m. till sunrise
taking the toad Wow every hour every
hour and we just you know went getting
deeper and deeper this is a fascinating
metal so you don't build up any kind of
tolerance to it or not with toad not we
thought you may have to do some
adjustments to the dose but there's no
no need to yeah no rest wow it's amazing
mount calls you well I'm really proud of
you Mike dad's on gradual ations dude
well you went and did something very few
people have the courage to do are you
serious yeah there's a lot of people
that are scared to do that oh yeah oh
absolutely because of how deep it takes
you you know it takes you to a place
that a lot of people are scared to go to
yeah and you said it yourself I'm gonna
quote you Mike you said this this meant
this
this thing takes you to to your nature
to get to know who you are and you might
not like it but but that's what it does
it takes you to the nature of the self
that's in your words but that's pretty
much what you shared to me I could feel
the energy that this whole experience
just sitting out here in the room it's
really palpable yeah absolutely
it's it's pretty powerful man well I
don't know if I didn't know was like
some exact one - do it - yeah yeah yeah
love to see Zack afterwards right
afterwards I gotta like fade that first
and I can't help but to finally turn it
through disjoint overhead it's like hey
that was the first thing yeah well dr.
Jerry talked a little bit about that the
the synergistic effects of cannabinoids
and DMT well it's known that cannabis
depending on the strain has a very
specific effect on the experience for
example sativa strains tend to
reactivate the medicine while indica
tends to help integrate tend to ground
yourself so that can be taken also as an
admixture no sir if you're taking
shrooms or LSD and you know you take a
puff and boom you're gonna blast off
again yeah if it's sativa interesting
and if it's like whoa he said no I can
see that stuff mean addicting I think I
might want to go there again really
again and again few people few people
really identify with the medicine and
with the process and I definitely have
some groupies that follow me all over
the world that you know are fond of the
medicine Isaac I personally take it once
a month I think it helps me to realign
myself to remember my purpose and it's
like a self whipping mechanism or like a
like remember no it was it works for me
at least yeah hey don't let these
[ __ ] in your life each other
really yeah hey stop the [ __ ] right now
I wanted to start writing about cush and
I would hide you know no once those
reactors I dated [ __ ] you're still
there you're still present even when
you're having this experience well the
thing is the way this medicine works is
that it starts by dissolving the ego
gradually so it's a process that you
know it's just getting stronger and
stronger and stronger and it's not until
we
go that the ego or self completely
dissolves that we go to the next step
which is the entheogenic phase and that
usually takes two pathways if we have to
do some healing there might be some
release of vomiting saliva speeding
screaming crying it depends on the
individual on the personality but there
is a release a healing mode if not the
antigenic phase can take the route of a
divine message there is a message that
usually delivered to each and every one
of us that's gonna help us be a better
man a better person have a deeper
appreciation of life and I mean as soon
as we come back from that we're like
whoa exactly whatever when I was after I
would mean to the girl she's pricing
that many times before oh yeah yeah oh
yeah it's awesome
I'm so stoked for you man and dr. Jerry
it's pretty cool man yeah getting having
this having Mike Tyson you know continue
this message on from his his place in
the universe he's a champ I told him
you're the that's so awesome
anything else you want to say Mike you
know amazing man you'll get more clarity
I assure you
yeah I'm just gonna continue to unravel
itself know that stuff right do you
think that's do you think it should be
available and that should definitely
that that like like we spoke before no
this can have a huge potential and have
many applications and I haven't met a
person who hasn't benefited even if they
have a very dark and negative or I don't
like to call it negative just the
challenging process even if they go to
that they feel great they you know they
feel the change
and the universe is going to smile back
at you stronger brother like it's it's
it's really palpable the changes on the
body on the mind post-exposure so stay
in touch
let me know how you know because I'm the
reports are that you everyone has a
better appreciation of life they deal
with stressful if they should you know
it it really does a huge rewiring on the
brain so yeah and you still want to do
it again that's because you know it
works yeah joy the high this time yeah I
won't be like freaked out and stuff I
would be like a flower child next and
it's only nice hi guys yeah the guy was
talking about my friend I was talking
about earlier the one that he actually
saved from addiction he had to do it
twice as well cuz the first time he
fought it a little bit he didn't get the
full experience and the second time
really really really cured him and
helped him a lot saved his life amazing
it's amazing them well thank you so much
let's hit it
maybe Michael do it again but until next
time thank you dr. dark thank you well
it's awesome man imagine when you're
back in LA after your world tour and you
go one time people wanna try it up to it
he travel yes he currently does that
already yeah how many years you've been
doing the film of that that's gonna be
awesome anyway a film doing that they've
done a few short like how to call them
documentary yeah documentaries about my
work yeah we've been around I've been
working now like traveling non-stop for
more than three years Wow I just flew in
from London and you know flying now to
Uzbekistan
so yeah it's busy schedule awesome well
we'll keep him the great work and I
thank your brother not to be here thank
you yeah thank you Mike there the child
doctor [ __ ] yeah doctor [ __ ] Jerry
alright guys until next time we're out
of here spreading that 11 hi that's
right
have anything good after
[Music]